What I want to do in this
video is review what we
learned from our chemistry
classes about oxidation and
the opposite of oxidation,
reduction.
And then see how what we learned
in our chemistry class
relates to the way that a
biologist or biochemist might
use these words.
And hopefully we'll see that
they're the same thing.
So just as a bit of review, if
you watched the chemistry
playlist. Oxidation, you can
view it-- and actually there's
a famous mnemonic for it.
It's: OIL RIG Where the oil
tells us that oxidation is
losing-- I put it in quotes
because you're not necessarily
losing the electrons; I'll
show you what I mean-- is
losing electrons.
This is what you should
have learned in
your chemistry class.
And then you also learned that
reduction is gaining.
And I'll put that in
quotes as well.
Is gaining electrons.
And I put that in quotes because
you're not necessarily
gaining electrons.
You're more hogging it.
And the reason why it's called
reduction, is because if you
are gaining electrons your
notional charge, if you really
were gaining them,
is being reduced.
And the reason why this is
called oxidizing is because
you tend to lose electrons
to oxygen.
Although it doesn't
have to be oxygen.
It could be any molecule
that will hog
electrons away from you.
And I think a nice example would
be fair to kind of make
this a little bit
more concrete.
Let's say I took some molecular
hydrogen, it's in a
gaseous state, and I were to
combust that with some
molecular oxygen.
This is what happened
on the Hindenburg.
They filled a balloon full of
hydrogen and you get a little
bit of spark, expose it to
oxygen, and you're going to
have a big explosion.
But in the process, for every
mole of molecular oxygen, if
you have two moles of molecular
hydrogen-- I'm just
making sure the equation is
balanced-- you're going to
produce two moles of H2O
plus a ton of heat.
This thing is really
going to blow.
What I want to do, I mean
we could talk about the
Hindenburg but really, the whole
reason why I even wrote
this is, I want to show you what
is getting oxidized and
what is getting reduced.
So in this situation right
here on the hydrogen, the
molecular hydrogen just
looks like this.
You have a hydrogen-hydrogen
bond.
They're each sharing an electron
with the other one so
that they both can pretend
their 1s orbital
is completely filled.
So they're not losing electrons
to each other.
They're not hogging electrons
one from the other.
So we say that they have a
neutral oxidative state.
They haven't gained
or lost electrons.
They're just sharing them.
And the same thing is true
for the molecular oxygen.
And here you actually
have a double bond
with the two oxygens.
But they're both oxygens, so
there's no reason why one
would gain or lose electrons
from the other.
But when you go on this side
of the equation, something
interesting happens.
You have, for every oxygen is
connected to two hydrogens.
And the way to think about is
that oxygen is hogging each of
these hydrogen's electrons.
So hydrogen has this one
electron on its valence shell.
The deal with most covalent
bonding is, hey, I give you an
electron, you give me an
electron and we both have a
complete pair.
But we know, or hopefully we
can review, that oxygen is
much more electronegative
than hydrogen.
This is a little bit of glucose
that's left over from
our cellular restoration
video.
You can ignore it for now but
I'm going to connect all this
in a future video.
But if we look at our periodic
table, if you remember from
the chemistry playlist,
electronegativity increases as
we go to the top right of
the periodic table.
These are the most
electronegative elements over
here, these are the least
electronegative.
And all electronegative means
is, likes to hog electrons.
So even though oxygen and
hydrogen are in a covalent
bond in water-- they're sharing
electrons-- oxygen is
more electronegative, much
more electronegative than
hydrogen, so it's going
to hog the electrons.
And actually if you take some
elements on this side and you
bond them with some guys over
here, these guys are so much
more electronegative than these
left-hand elements that
they'll actually completely
steal the electron, not just
hog it for most of the time.
But when you talk
electronegativity, it just
means, likes the electrons.
So when you look at this bond
between hydrogen and oxygen,
we saw from the periodic table,
oxygen is a lot more
electronegative, so the
electrons spend a lot more
time on oxygen.
We learned about hydrogen
bonding.
We learned that it creates a
partial negative charge on
that side of the water molecule
and creates partial
positive charges on this side.
And electrons still show
up around the hydrogens
every now and then.
When you talk about oxidation
and reduction you say, look
there's no partial charge.
If one guy is kind of hogging
the electron more, for the
sake of oxidation states, we're
going to assume that he
took the electron.
So for an oxidation state, we'll
assume that the oxygen
in water takes the electron
and we'll give him an
oxidation state of one minus.
Or the convention is, you write
the charge after the
number for oxidation states.
So you don't confuse it
with actual charges.
So this has a one minus because,
from an oxidation
state point of view, it's
taking the electron.
It's gaining the elctron.
That's why I put it in quotes.
Because you're not really
gaining it.
You're just gaining it
most of the time.
You're hogging electrons.
And likewise, this hydrogen--
let me be careful, this
isn't-- he got one electron from
this hydrogen and you got
another electron from
this hydrogen.
So instead of saying one minus,
it should be two minus.
It should be two minus, because
he's hogging one
electron from here and one
electron from there.
And in general, when oxygen is
bonding with other non-oxygen
atoms or non-oxygen elements,
it tends to have a two minus
or a negative two
oxidation state.
So if this guy's two
minus, because
he's gained two electrons.
Let me write that in quotes.
Gained two electrons.
We know that he really didn't
gain them, that he's just
hogging them.
These guys lost an
electron each.
So this guy's oxidation state
is going to be one plus.
And this guy's oxidation state
So you could say, by combusting
the hydrogen with
the oxygen, that the hydrogens--
before they had a
zero oxygen state, each of these
hydrogens had a zero
oxygen state-- now they have
a one plus oxidation state
because they lost their
electrons when they bonded
with the oxygen.
So we say that these hydrogens
have been oxidized.
So, due to this reaction,
hydrogen has been oxidized.
Why has it been oxidized?
Because before, it was
able to share its
electrons very nicely.
But then it bonds with oxygen,
which will hog its electrons.
So the hydrogen is losing its
electrons to the oxygen, so
it's been oxidized.
Similarly, the oxygen, due to
this combustion reaction, has
been reduced.
Why has it been reduced?
Here it was just sharing
electrons.
It wasn't losing
or gaining it.
But here when it's bonded with
an element with much lower
electronegativity, all of a
sudden it can start hogging
the electrons, it
gains electrons.
So this hypothetical charge
is reduced by two.
And if I wanted to actually
account for all of the
electrons, because we're talking
about losing electrons
and gaining electrons, we can
write two half reactions.
This should all be a little
bit of review from your
chemistry class.
But it never hurts to
see this again.
I'm going to throw this in the
biology playlist so that you
biology people can hopefully
refresh your
memory with this stuff.
We can write two
half reactions.
We could say that we started
off with two moles of
molecular hydrogen.
And they have no oxidation
states, or they're neutral.
So I could write a zero
there if I want.
And then I end up with-- on the
other side-- I end up with
two moles of H2.
But each of the hydrogens
now, have a plus
one oxidation state.
Or another way to think about it
is, each of these-- there's
four hydrogens here.
This is molecular hydrogen has
two hydrogens and we have two
moles of this.
So there are four
hydrogens here.
Each of the four hydrogens
lost an electron.
So I can write this.
So, plus four electrons.
That's the half reaction
for hydrogen.
It lost four electrons.
So this is another way of
saying that hydrogen is
oxidized because it
lost electrons.
OIL: oxidation is losing.
And then the other half
reaction, if I were to write
the oxygen.
So I'm starting with a mole of
molecular oxygen and I'm
adding to that four electrons.
I can't make electrons
out of nowhere.
I'm getting the electrons from
the hydrogen, I'm adding to
the oxygen.
And so the half reaction on this
side, I end up with two
moles-- I could write it like
this-- two moles of oxygen.
And each of them have an
oxidation state of two minus.
So these are the
half reactions.
And all this is showing is that
the hydrogen, over the
course of this combustion
reaction, lost electrons.
And that the oxygen gained the
electrons that the hydrogen
lost. So this tells us that
oxygen is reduced.
Now this is all fair and good
and this is all a bit of
review of what you learned
in chemistry class.
But now I'm going to make things
even more confusing.
Because I'm going to introduce
you to how a biologist
thinks about it.
So-- and it's not
always the case.
Sometimes the biologist will use
the definition you learned
in your chemistry class.
But a biologist-- or many
times in many biology
textbooks-- they'll say-- and
this used to confuse me to no
end, really-- that oxidation is
losing hydrogen atoms. And
reduction is gaining
hydrogen atoms.
And at first when I got exposed
to this, I was like, I
learned it in chemistry class
and they talk about electrons.
Hydrogen atoms, you know it's a
proton and an electron, how
does it relate?
And the reason why these two
definitions-- this is really
the whole point of this video--
the reason why this
definition is consistent with
this one is because in the
biological world hydrogen
is what tends
to get swapped around.
And it tends to bond with
carbon, oxygen,
phosphorous, nitrogen.
And if we look at the periodic
table, and we see where
hydrogen is, and we see where
carbon, nitrogen, oxygen and
phosphorous and really all this
other stuff is, you see
that all of the stuff that in
biological systems, hydrogen
tends to bond with, the things
it tends to bond with are
much, much more electronegative.
So if a carbon is bonding with
a hydrogen, the carbon is
hogging that electron.
And then if that hydrogen gets
transferred to an oxygen,
along with the electron, the
carbon will lose the hydrogen
atom, but it really lost
the electron that
it was hogging before.
And now the oxygen can
hog that electron.
So these are really consistent
definitions.
And the whole reason why I
showed you this example is
because the biological
definition doesn't apply here.
I mean, you could say, well,
oxygen is definitely gaining
hydrogens in this reaction.
So we can definitely say that
oxygen is being reduced still,
according to the biological
definition.
But you can't really say
that hydrogen is
losing hydrogens here.
In this situation, hydrogen
is just losing electrons.
It's not losing itself.
I guess you could say it's
losing itself because it's
being taken over.
But the biological definition
just comes
from the same notion.
That when hydrogen bonds with
most things in biological
compounds, it tends to
give the electrons.
So if a carbon loses a hydrogen
and gives it to an
oxygen, the carbon will lose
that hydrogen's electron that
it was able to hog.
And now the oxygen
is hogging it.
So the carbon would be oxidized
and the oxygen would
be reduced.
Hope that doesn't confuse you.
In the next video I'll show you
a couple more examples.
And the whole reason why I'm
doing this is to apply this to
cellular respiration.
So that you don't get confused
when people talk and say that,
oh the NAD is being reduced when
it picks up the hydrogen.
Or it's being oxidized when it
loses the hydrogen, and so
forth and so on.
I wanted you to see that these
are the same definitions that
you learned in your
chemistry class.